[Music]  kendall Jenner opening up about how life  has changed since Kylie became a mom  Kendall serving supermodel realness on  the cover of Elle's June issues inside  the 22 year old reveals her true  feelings on 20 year-old Kylie's  pregnancy quote it's obviously a bit  weird that your little sister is having  a baby before you I didn't expect it to  happen like this  but it's beautiful since Kylie and  boyfriend Travis Scott welcomed their  daughter stormy in February Kendall says  her newborn niece has only made their  sisterly bond stronger quote it's  brought us closer together we've always  been very close but we would butt heads  all the time this has made her a bit  more loving toward me I've taught my  kids from day one you know family's  everything so that comes first  [Music]  [Applause]